I am up three to five times a night to urinate.
What could be the reason for this?
Is there a test I could take to find out the cause?
So, there's several reasons why a person
would get up to go to the bathroom.
You could have, if you have a tumor in your abdomen
that's pressing on your bladder, you have a smaller bladder
and you're getting this sensation
that you have to go to the bathroom
because you have an increased pressure on your bladder sphincter.
So, how your bladder sphincter works neurologically,
it sends a message to your brain to wake you up
if there's a lot of pressure on it.
If you have an abnormal, a lot of pressure,
simply because the tumor is putting physical pressure on the bladder
thereby decreasing the volume of fluid
that the bladder can hold without putting pressure on the sphincter
and it's signaling to your body to get up to go to the bathroom.
There isn't a whole lot you can do about that.
The bladder sphincter is controlled by your parasympathetic nervous system.
So, working on parasympathetic nervous system exercises
could be helpful.
So, let's say a person doesn't have a tumor in their abdominal cavity
putting pressure on the bladder,
so everything I just said is null and void.
Well, other reasons why a person don't have to get up to go to the bathroom.
They're male, obviously, the first thing is prosthetic hypertrophy.
And so, they're not getting well emptied of the bladder
or they're getting that sensation that they have to get up to go to the bathroom
three and a four times a day.
And let's take that out of the picture, male or female.
That's not an issue.
And what are some other reasons?
If a person is stuck in sympathetic tone,
they're going to have an increased need to your day and night.
So, your sympathetic nervous system,
that's why if you're scared and you're frightened,
you lose control of your bladder,
you could pee yourself a little bit, right?
Because that's a, you're in a sympathetic overtone.
You lose parasympathetic neurological condition of the tone of the sphincter
and you can, and you can lose, you know, you can urinate a little bit.
So, you doing some parasympathetic exercises would be helpful.
So, go back to the blog, search parasympathetic.
I have a video on it.
I am downloads of how to stimulate your vagal nerve
that's your parasympathetic, how to calm your sympathetic.
That's your mess and cephalon.
So, mess and cephalon, call me exercises.
That's sympathetic call me exercises in parasympathetic or vagal stimulated exercises.
Those are some things I would think of on it.
Other possibilities are a person has a UTI, something like that.
That's not an uncommon thing to have that you have to deal with.
As far as testing for that.
And testing for a UTI would be even just do it in your dipstick.
If that shows up any type of bacteria, that's a possibility.
If it's viral, it won't show off of that.
So, as far as is there a test to find out the cause.
You'd kind of walk through those pieces first.
If you do a standard blood test of CBC and you showed an elevated white blood cell count.
Then you'd consider an infection as well as that.
It's not would be necessarily specific to the bladder or anything like that,
but you could look at your symptoms and figure that out.
And then again, with the elevated white blood cell count on CBC,
you'd look at it for an elevated neutrophil count versus an elevated lymphocytic count.
And that's how you'd help determine whether it's a viral infection or a bacterial infection as far as.